if you saw of that feel that you would
be amazed pyramids built by Jewish
slaves that's a fact
in the Bible we know this who got the
Jews free that's for Moses hello it is
me Chris I am in Australia right now
hence this if you are in Perth in
Western Australia I am doing two
different shows at the Fringe world
festival target demographic and rap God
the links to those are in the
description please come along and say hi
if you are in Los Angeles I am
performing a headline set at the comedy
a magic club on March the 26th come and
see me there if you are in New York I am
planning on doing a week-long run of my
show rap God there in April sometime
we're just trying to figure out the
dates if you're not in any other places
I'm really sorry but I will be trying to
put together a tour in 2021 which sounds
super futuristic but is actually only
next year and hopefully I'll be able to
come to where you are unless you live in
a really obscure place like Tegucigalpa
which is a real place because I rapped
about it like four months ago some of
you may know that I do freestyle raps
through a website called cameo you can
book me to do a freestyle rap about you
about your friend about your partner
they're running a Valentine's Day
special right now I think for the next
week you can get raps from me for $75
which is 25% off so if you want that
then do that thank you very much for
watching here to reward you is a
freestyle rap from the small room at the
comedy & magic club so the sound isn't
as good but I thought the rap was really
fun so I thought you would enjoy seeing
it thank you very much for watching
enjoy the rap you put a hand up which is
so polite yeah rutabagas they are what
we would call turnips or Swedes right
yeah I kind of which one they are no
it's a rudeboy turnip or a Swede it's a
rutabaga you limey yeah cool rude babies
mean technically it's a food by also
feels a food that no one's really eaten
for about 25 years have they so well how
would you eat a rutabaga how would you
prepare it steam and salted that's
probably a good way to do it well done
well done for the seasoning at the end
so important
cool steamed insulted rutabagas I like
that as a suggestion actually people in
the the
corner over here this square of tables
we've got steamed and salted rutabagas
it's a very pleasing phrase to say isn't
it steamed and salted rutabagas steamed
and so it sounds like a euphemism for
someone who's really drunk
well he steamed them solid so guys over
here I just give you some thinking time
what baby oh baby Oda was suggested last
night I'm afraid do you say child labor
that wasn't suggested last night because
no one is a nihilistic fiend child labor
I mean the thing is I don't you know
this obviously the mandalorian from
which baby Yoda is a character I mean
also called the child isn't name's not
baby Yoda Disney wanted to hide that
they were making a baby Yoda and so they
couldn't make merchandise of baby Yoda
lest a kind of leak happen in the supply
chain but now baby at the odor is so
popular may I'm talking police officer
[ __ ] Walt Disney going past me like
no we've letting our secret slip but
what happened is the Mandalorian came
out they didn't have the supply line all
Serbs they couldn't do the baby let's go
can I've said now they're gonna have to
rush him out and it's gonna be like
April so you can buy a baby Yoda it's
not funny but I'm just explaining why
there were no baby Yoda toys at
Christmas but child labor is a
suggestion section is for that front of
the room people on the front I like you
guys cuz you're both wearing denim what
would you like to hear a rap about you
cool young things well that feels too
on-the-nose doesn't it I feel that that
you might think that's some kind of
Darren brown mentalism trick it's got
something different literary that's a
whole personality Chris that's the I
like jean-jacques I just don't look good
in them you can help out as well
Egyptian pyramids cool thank you for
clarifying as well because you know we
could have been going on you know Incan
or something as well Egyptian pyramids I
I'm trying to think if we can add some
into that should make it a bit more fun
Egyptian pyramids
give me an adjective upside down okay
cool upside down a jig Egyptian pyramids
cool upside down Egyptian pyramids child
labor steaming of salted rutabagas
middle of the room let's get something
Keith Richards yeah okay cool fear for
the younger people he's the the immortal
guitarist of The Rolling Stones somehow
you will not die despite the fact that
he looks like he's taking every drug
known to humankind and some that we
haven't discovered yet so Keith Richards
and back at the room just you know what
you've got a kind of beat so far steamed
in salted rutabagas upside-down Egyptian
pyramids of child labor Keith Richards
so back of the room let's kind of come
up with the best one so far this could
be anything the Falkland the Falkland
Island Wars the Falkland Islands were
suggested in the main room this club
about three months ago on again I don't
take the sense Jeff I know I did a
really good rap about it I was rhyming
[ __ ] like Malvinas and everything
because that's what the Austin tnews
call them let's come on let's get
something Home Depot it's not as
exciting as the Falkland Wars but it
hasn't been suggested before so by by my
own rule to have to take it okay why why
do someone down here go Home Depot as
well you really into that is it a good
store I mean I'm only just now realizing
that it's not pronounced deep hot so
that's great are they are HMDA pot what
a lovely shot that looks like I'll be
sure to go in there an order but hasten
to pots right guys we've got it it's
I've done it very slowly but we've got
them all they were to remind you upside
down Egyptian pyramid home depot child
labor steamed insulted rutabagas and
what was I find a lot of it off me guys
Keith Richards okay this then lovely
people to close out the night a little
treat for you guys the freestyle rap
that has a rap made up on the spot based
in Thailand those suggestions never been
seen before
will never be seen again do not worry it
will not be anywhere near as atrociously
embarassingly toe-curling ly bad as you
are expecting a privately educated
middle class white British boy to be
you see very unconvinced but that's fine
Dwain if we can roll that beat let's
have another Granny's house she says
what I'm gonna make you put it in the
pot nice rutabaga in the UK you should
heed my advice don't say that word say
sweet or turn it if I turn my nose if
you give me anything
look grows in the garden what me women
your I never really worn out on my place
so much ignore I'm not sure what her
skills can be faulted she slice it up
then steamed and salted put in the bow
about 20 minutes maybe 50 more before
it's finished then take that out it
tastes really great I like it with the
seasoning on my plate the only little
thing that could make it bear a bit more
condiment add in there pepper such an
expensive urban spice and if I'm in the
Middle East then my advise you to go
more to North Africa you can have a lot
of fun in a wrapper there and if you
really think you need to go get off the
harbour near Cairo travel down the Nile
babies with the Delta when you see the
architecture you will smell like things
well enough you can call it all never
seen something as amazing this before so
big you can see them from the shore you
can count them in the Valley of the
Kings 4-1 cos there's only three the
best one is Khufu I'd agree I've never
visited you've got read a lot about it
what about this
screaming shower I can improve that
structure greatly your flip back seat
give it 180 not 360 that's a circle it's
hard to lift so it's really hurtful if
you sort of that feel that you would be
amazed pyramids built by Jewish slaves
that's a fact in the Bible we know this
who got the Jews free that's for Moses
he was like no you silly kids who come
away leave those black pyramids come on
follow me I'm doing you a favor don't
work hard like child labour in the
factories in China put a plan people
build it in Vietnam and Taiwan all of
the kids who work don't need any money
so big fingers bleed I'm not being funny
in our home but we could get lots of
things like on mobile phones built by
children in Foxconn if you can i phone
then you've got one a product made by
underage kids we should all feel good so
enraged I will even go so far as to go
there if you had a plush for your baby
Yoda that would also be made by a
toddler to you would take it to your bed
it would color with you you would say I
love you baby Yoda you're amazing I
touch who knows that but still a child
had a big part in making that thing
giving it a plush heart let me move on
yet forget the sick kids talk about
rockstars Keith Richards he's amazing
even at his age he'd have the guitar
right on stage go in here I'm an old
bloke I've got the whole power from the
lines of coke I did it backstage and I
played that riff give me shelter cuz I
need it because I look like a mum in
late 90s who pleased everybody
I agree so we take Keith Richards
shuffle his feet he looks like a man who
sleeps on the street hold my hand keep
you're my hero come in here its Home
Depot what we gonna do ask me why I'm
gonna get a 2x4 DIY we're gonna build a
nice new shed for you there we go go in
what you're gonna do well I'm gonna call
all my best mates round Mick Jagger yeah
he's in town what you're gonna do when
you hear game thrills now we're gonna
test out power drills and then we're
gonna get screws get nuts and bolts
Home Depot it's not my fault that never
really got the word life support I
thought it was pronounced duty pot I'm
very very sorry that I've got the [ __ ]
wrong but there we go that's Home Depot
in a song he's
amazing yes I have I'm sorry that we
couldn't rap about the four plants why
I've already done that before
technically who was the even the war
Argentina were like that's ours and we
were like no we're a much greater power
than yours
[ __ ] off Argentina they asked they still
are yeah Her Majesty is the older that's
our team British Parliament yeah we've
got the Queen Argentina crime yeah we've
all seen this down the shore up that
could be saying Malvinas we want to own
them now they spoiled why do we have
them because they contain oil yeah
[Applause]
thank you good better fun